why
Being here is difficult, I say you can not
deny it we can not cover the sun with
a finger not as they say out there but be
in the band is a privilege is a gift
where it has helped me a lot in the
psychological sense most of
time to be on that side is a
roll because you live with many people
of enduring and character of the people
to endure then encierro and all that is
very difficult very difficult then the
being here making music allows me
free me totally
as is
two
that's the coolest thing about playing in
a scenario because seeing the band
is rocanroleando and spinning their
blows people dancing in the visit
must be screaming until we
remember ballast a misfortune our
mom dressed because look for band did not pass
because